please wait
you know i've covered a lot of companies
i've covered a lot of
uh machiavellian companies where you
know people play rough
i don't think i've ever seen anything on
the scale of nissan
he's making you but you know
one of the most dramatic elements was
ravinder posse's home
uh being raided by uh court officials in
yokohama
you scared me
[Music]
journey into the the darkest recesses
of the japanese corporate world started
when he was the general counsel
the highest corporate lawyer position in
the company
in the past few minutes nissan has
revealed that its chairman
has been arrested after allegations of
serious misconduct he was tasked
with investigating carlos gown
and he was told conduct an internal
investigation and get to the heart of
the matter
and then along the way he started to
notice serious conflicts of interest
he is one of the few people who knows
an extreme amount of detail regarding
the alleged crime by pearl scone and
he's now ready to tell his own story on
the record
about some of the events that happened
um my name is ravinder passi i'm the
former global general counsel of nissan
motorco limited
um and you could say yes i had a front
row seat
in terms of what was going on when
carlos gone
saved nissan years ago he was depicted
in japanese comic books as this hero and
and now maybe we'll see comic books
where he's the villain
in corporate japan nissan was quite an
unusual company
it was led for two decades by
a non-japanese executive
well carlos gone was a hero in the
japanese business world
if you had a global business celebrity
in japan
and worldwide it was definitely carlos
scone
in a country with few foreigners at the
top he stood out
but over the years he saved nissan from
bankruptcy
allied with renault and mitsubishi and
turned the alliance into one of the most
competitive in the world
yet as the years went on you know he i
think his ambitions changed a little bit
he started thinking about legacy plays
and one of them
was to really tighten the alliance
between
renault and japan uh and unbeknownst to
him
there was a contingent of senior nissan
executives
that were really uh felt threatened by
that move
they really thought that they would lose
complete control of the
the the car company and even in the
government there was probably a little
bit of
anxiety about a national champion
in the auto industry falling under
full-blown foreign control
carlos gone was an auto industry leader
respected by
many in japan now he's in jail
the arrest of carlos gone came
completely out of the blue
this was in november of 2018 he was
coming to japan
on nissan's corporate jet for a regular
executive meeting and he was met on the
tarmac by japanese authorities
who whisked him away to a jail
and charged him with financial
misconduct crimes
so what happened was a power struggle
ensued
inside the company and somewhere along
the way
it was criminalized by that i mean
that there were allegations leveled at
carlos gone about
the way he reported his pay to japanese
authorities
the way he handled money inside the
company
that in other contexts might have been a
board action might have been
handled internally a number of
executives
at nissan decided to take this this
difference
and take it over to the tokyo
prosecutor's office and that unleashed
a chain of events that would shake the
entire auto industry
[Music]
so after carlos gohan was arrested
nissan launched an internal
investigation
into the events that led up to his
arrest
so rob posse was tasked with
investigating carlos gown and he was
told
get to the heart of the matter find out
what carlos stone
did wrong and bring it to our
shareholders
yeah it's really complicated because you
had
various things coming out of the wheat
2018 the investigation has has started
and we become
aware of matters in terms of conflicts
actions by certain individuals
that cause some concern because things
might not
quite be what they seem
so in our story we really took a close
look at harinada and his role
in carlos gone's downfall hari nada is
one of the most fascinating figures
inside nissan he's also a lawyer
he's originally malaysian
and he had a meteoric rise through the
company
and became very very close to carlos
gone and other top
figures he had a front row seat at
all the major strategic deliberations at
the at the company
and when he discovered that carlos gone
as his final legacy play was going to
tighten the relationship between
renault and nissan he made a decision
to go against carlos scone and he became
one of the key figures that decided that
carlos cohn had to go
harry nader was somebody who actually
recruited me into the company so i have
a long-standing
uh relationship with him or did have a
long-standing relationship with him
um for many many years he was a mentor
i had doubts about the credibility of
the pro of the process
right at the start harry and i had a
plea deal
with the tokyo prosecutors
now that suggests he was intrinsically
involved
in some of the wrongdoing or the
allegations of wrongdoing
and it just didn't smell right just
doesn't sit right
so there was a basic conflict of
interest in other words
harinada had to deliver results
to japanese prosecutors to avoid his own
criminal
liability and he's accusing and leading
the investigation
of carlos gown some of the people who
had been involved
in the original alleged crimes were also
looking into the affairs themselves
ravinder posse began pointing out
some of these conflict of interest
issues and the reason for that is
essentially his concern was for the
company
if the company's own investigation into
itself was compromised
that could lead to a very weak position
in various lawsuits that it was dealing
with across the world
i had discussions with harry discussions
about
with the statutory auditors about these
conflicts
discussions with hr about some of these
conflicts because at that point
we reported into him you know at the
time everything was quite
as you can imagine it was we've got to
do this we've got to do that we've got
to move fast
but when you step back and look at some
of these things you just think
my god what was going on here because
me members of my team were being placed
in
immediate danger
your chairman's been arrested a
representative director has
been arrested they both happen to be
foreigners
and then now what we need to do we're
being instructed to do is certain
compliance professionals
need to go into properties in brazil for
example
and retrieve evidence they've got to do
it very carefully because if they don't
do it carefully
they're going to get convicted of
criminal activities
and likewise when a team of lawyers were
commissioned to go to lebanon
i mean one of my immediate concerns was
why are
lawyers from nissan being sent to go to
lebanon
to retrieve evidence these are just
lawyers they're corporate lawyers from
nissan
you had revelations that
a number of executives had benefited
from share appreciation rights when they
shouldn't have i mean
you know substantive amounts of money
being taken by these guys when they
weren't entitled to take them
and you do think yes how is this going
to look
later on it's going to look quite
concerning
so that triggered for me
the sort of assessment that well i'm
gonna have to do something
because up until this point
i haven't put down on paper these
conflicts
and these issues
so rob posse makes a fateful move he
writes this letter to the board
listing every uh suspicion he has
in great detail backed up by evidence
backed up by memos
of why this internal investigation had
serious problems
he sends a letter to the board and it's
crickets he doesn't hear much of
anything
nothing happened thereafter nothing at
all just
like it just gone into a black box and
uh he began to suspect that
uh there was a desire even at the
highest level within nissan
to uh kind of sweep these conflicts of
interest under the rug
unfortunately for me i think
you know again with hindsight people
must have thought that this is
the nail that's sticking out and we
can't have this
within three days of me submitting that
to the
board of directors that letter to the
independent board of directors
i was removed from the go and executive
conduct matters i was then told
that i could not attend board meetings
anymore
and up until that point i had attended
every single board meeting
i was then also told that after eight
years of being in japan
i'd be going back to the uk
it eventually transpired that i'd be the
vp of projects and transformation
managing a team of three
so you can imagine what this feels like
at this stage
almost an arbitrary removal from japan
where i've lived for eight years had
three children there my
family has grown up and we've been
settled there having
a few months earlier been promoted to
vice president at a global level
to being almost demoted
so posse was essentially being
reassigned
to get him as far away from the internal
investigation
as possible and also to a certain extent
in retaliation to some of the issues
that he brought up regarding
the internal investigation and harinada
what happened to rav posse can be seen
as a series of
of corporate humiliations i mean first
of all his
immediate responsibilities were taken
away from him eventually he lost
you know the coveted general counsel
title but it didn't stop
there toward the end of his stay in
japan
rav and his wife were convinced that
they were being followed
[Music]
during that period i'd noticed
that whilst driving my car i'd have
other cars following me
[Music]
first time i noticed this was around
mid-march
and i was driving i can't remember where
i was going but this gray van
small van just literally started
following me
and i noticed there was somebody in the
car taking pictures
and lo and behold we were absolutely
being followed by either by people
on foot or other individuals
two or three normally two burly men
in a car different cars at different
times following us around
they were following the family as well
and you know given
um we'd seen
or i'd seen the nissan security
department behave in
a very very egregious manner with others
in terms of
following and surveilling
i was very concerned as to what they
were doing and who they were giving this
information
to because if they're giving this
information
to the authorities you do think why
what's going on here i mean this is just
not normal
behavior and this all uh
culminated in a rather dramatic event
uh in the middle of 2020. who are you
people
where nissan had hired
a legal team and had obtained an unusual
court order from the district court in
yokohama to basically
do a a search and and of
of his home and seizure of his you know
corporate laptop
and and phone and other another document
if you don't let us in now we have to
break this
key so it's a pretty extreme way to
treat someone who'd spent 16 years at
the company
these people have all come in we don't
really know who they are
apart from the fact that i've been shown
a badge that says the yokohama court
and they're here to recover a laptop
and a mobile phone it was even more
weird
because i'd highlighted to the directors
that their
that certain nissan executives were
trying to recover this laptop and this
phone
whilst i was still in japan and
i was very concerned because it had
evidence on there that related to
misconduct matters and other forms of
inappropriate conduct it was just an
another form of intimidation another
form of harassment
forcing me almost to leave the company
and the country
because once they'd retained and
obtained these items
[Music]
we were still followed which again i
just couldn't understand
what is the point of doing that
you know this isn't a car company this
is not the kgb
[Music]
i think it's fair to say that rob posse
didn't have full battlefield
awareness of all the intrigue
going on at nissan i mean harinata is
interesting because he's both
charismatic and charming
and one of the most brutal corporate in
fighters one could ever run across this
is a confidential company email right
you should not have this
if he had fallen into line he would
probably
still have his job at nissan be paid
very well and continued his work a
career that he spent
you know 16 years building at nissan is
is
irretrievably broken it's been smashed
to smith
smithereens uh he and his family
paid a huge price certainly but in terms
of being able to sleep at night i think
you know he's come out ahead i
highlighted issues
to the highest levels of the company
so that they could be dealt with
appropriately by those in charge
there was no response to those and there
was retaliation
against me what's really profound
like absolutely profound is that
none of your colleagues i mean people
who you have known for years
forget it yeah you're on your own yeah
and um
yeah you got to be ready for that
you've got to be ready for that
if you take it on anyway
you